what's happening there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to watch Black
Mirror season 6 episode 3. it's the one
with Aaron Paul I'm excited John how are
you feeling I could not be giddier for
Aaron Paul on Black Mirror he was
actually I believe a voice in the on
that Rift on Star Trek with Jesse
Clemons I'm number six and I believe he
had a voice there that's a fun fact for
you I'll leave a like on this video that
would mean the world also subscribe
click the notification Bell because we
are getting through these episodes oh
it's one more thing oh yes full
interaction watch along where you sync
it with their own copy of Black Mirror
available for a super sexy Rejects at
our patreon page thank you to all who
have been joining so far we've been
getting so many pledge encumbersome
movie reactions and many of you have
joined us for Black Mirror alone so
thank you guys they also cover several
things exclusive over there with
rational Heights and watch alongs
included let's watch this show
sweetheart
I'm gonna scratch your nose try to go
back Josh partner damn
it's cool to see him here I loved his
work in Westworld oh rest in peace rest
in peace
hey
hey is that Amora well Kate not Amara
the name hey Mara you're David Ross I
believe I am
it's an honor to meet you sir oh my God
such an honor you're the porn star David
Rose
on the smut theater
there are you like
like it's a kind of sleep The Human
Experience the survival of the human
body of life that's really Central to
the mission she's so tired whoa
so he's not actually here our Lord
heavenly father bless us and these thy
gifts which we take from thy Bountiful
goodness through Jesus Christ Our Lord
amen is he also in space
I guess it's safe to assume are these
like avatars oh and it's a clear win for
Lily
nice parking job people smoking reefer
in that van
hippies
what passion
leave the room John yeah sorry I have a
duty to attend to
[Laughter]
have fun
that's why this episode's so long
this goes on for at least 10 minutes
sorry sweetheart I gotta go this Josh
Arnett is unusually good looking yeah
come again sorry
I have to go
such distance between them and uh
juxtaposing of the city life and the
country life
oh
it's interesting they said it in the
past yeah like the height of the Space
Race too there is a crack in the silver
coating
ah cool
[Music]
this music cue is like Halloween it's
just them two
[Music]
nope
how's the new home it's good
Henry liking the country air he'll grow
into it and Lana
Cape Ann gonna be Cosmopolitan enough
for her
fish Island when's our next physical
Friday I'll see you Friday
have a good week you too
weekend astronauts Josh Hardin it's
evolved to have a bit of a Brad Pitt
thing about him oh yeah good call now is
is it the Clone in space you know what I
mean yeah so why wouldn't you just put
the Clone in space
just let it be there all day yeah
maybe we should have a little party
I don't know
be good for Henry to meet some local
kids
we'll see
that means no
arms perfectly
hop into your third body in the kitchen
how many chairs do you have in this
house
get out of my house
oh we've met the machine man is this the
Manson people Kappa oh this is Sigma
Theta and that's Epsilon we are Greeks
you're in my house
indeed we are
talking
nothing has to happen
No Stranger the crowd get down because
Casey at the bathroom
Casey at the bats good reference and the
Mighty Casey has struck out
get him in position come on
lay his arm out
whoa let's see what's inside your hand
is he a cyborg that is a tough steak
[Music]
oh
you are nothing natural my friend Sigma
give me your hammer Theta get his family
no
try to work out where you are
what
oh no he's gonna need to get back home
oh no please not my children please we
just want to find out who else is a
machine Mr Bunny freaks we're real
blood real blood and your kids are real
yeah
I'm sorry to report that's immaterial
man sleeps in the sky and you share your
bed with this abomination
you don't actually care about that
divine nature must have a cost or what
will become of us all you and yes the
children Wowzer
with his heart screaming a million miles
above us
insanely disturbing
wow
is very very disturbing cruel
hello
what the hell are you saying
oh
man he's trapped up there now
do you love a paranoid Space movie Leave
Me Alone
I'm so sorry
watch your back man he told me to get
out spoke to ground control and Holland
says she's sleeping baby I'll be in
shock what if he hijacks his body
he'll get revenge
he protected natural order I ride to him
by step
they comfort me
paying attention yeah
yeah I'm real afraid he's gonna try and
like hijack his family share the body
yeah
hey
right
foreign
okay
sure
this is very fascinating yeah
ominous
the man is lost
I can't reach him and I don't know what
to do
let's read in Valley of the Dolls what
if you let him use your link
as in
just for an hour yeah okay
feels a breeze on his face
oh man I don't know sleep with her yeah
know the Comforts of a loving wife
drive to California
how would you feel about using my link
would you like that
I think I'd like that very much
oh this is gonna be terrible
no good deed goes unpunished
foreign
Paul and his wife are distant yeah he's
gonna take his entire life opening of
this Josh Hartnett and his wife were
very intimate
he's just gonna smell the air and go
back up
it's all it's gonna be
would you like to see the forest
yes
that is beautiful
this is my favorite spot
I wonder if she's ever showed the actual
Cliff this
you're so clear
I've forgotten
damn that looks like a real caterpillar
wow this is like true sci-fi this is
like Terence Malek
damn this [__] is so haunting yeah
like at its core
oh
this is beautiful yeah like gut
wrenching but beautiful
he's totally banging my wife
so uh can I get my replica back
oh
your place
it's beautiful
your wife
hot
hotter than my old wife
yep I hope it's Patrick obsessive One
Taste oh boy I got like 15 different
emotions running through me at once yeah
lost and uncomfortable scared and
hopeful a little touched seems a little
lighter now
a poor man he wept like a child
in front of you
what did you do
not much
what could I even say
she enjoyed her time with him yeah
that's probably the first time she's
felt anything not strong in years you
did this for memory if I had this down
there I would hang it on the wall
you know
I could arrange that maybe get me a
canvas and some oils I could paint you
something like this for your home
like a thank you gift
you'd have to let me use your replica
again you might not want to do that
drawing helps
no matter how long would a painting take
for a little while obviously
six weeks really can't rush art you know
one hour
once a week while I'm doing the physical
skin set up his things up in the barn
there
clearly it has been on his mind
are you gonna explain this to your kids
the kids don't have to know but he's
gonna be like living out there half the
time just one hour a week that's fair
Daddy needs his barn time
God there's just so much pain in this
episode are you finding that Valley of
the Dolls can't say I'm crazy about it
my goodness it's trashy a guilty
pleasure yes
you like sci-fi
can't say I've tried it think of a few
recommendations for you
I'd like that and if it's getting
oh man why don't you pick up a copy of
the Kama Sutra
oh no
no dog you
oh yeah you want to go back to that Barn
this feels like old school black beer
yeah
[Music]
every time yeah
she's drawn to him
yeah he's everything she wishes Cliff
was
[Music]
this is so bad oh when will you paint me
have you done much painting
come over here I'll guide your hand
here
let me just try to add a little to the
tree there
guide her grab her hand yes come on show
her how to stroke the brush
uh ditto
totally see this coming
not cheating if it's the same body
damn shake hands he's getting too used
to this painting's looking good
[Laughter]
um
special of that bush yeah that one leaf
man so much character
there it is oh there it is no I mean his
reality is so painful
that this Escape is everything he needs
right now
everything okay
do you have any linseed oil I run out
I know that struggle is there a hardware
store in town
there's Mitchell's they'll be open
you think Cliff would mind would borrow
his car
we borrow his car
I thought you'd never ask
the location is a production value are
well thought out on this episode man
yeah hey I want to check the bookstore
out a moment
you want to come
sure
I'm also feeling in the mood for oysters
you want to come
if you like it
are you Cliff Stanfield
yes yes I was so sorry to hear about
what happened with your co-pilot
such a terrible thing no no dose of
reality no how is he doing
he's holding on
we really ought to be going
he gonna go Haywire
you okay uh oh the comforting
tense
now
yep
any time now it's oddly
familiar for her
must be confusing for her yes is is that
you added a mini
your mind here
Beyond the Sea
it's popular this is the 60s when people
especially sucked at communicating about
their emotions
yeah it's all yeah it's like all I
wanted is like Cliff open up Jesus
in some ways you're worse off than the
other guy oh she looks so happy uh oh
yep here it comes
[Music]
And So It Begins busting out the old
Playbook
must feel like she's not cheating
it's so confusing
must be so confusing
he looked at her like
what
he won't know
yes
no oh
you confused me work your way into my
home wearing my husband like a suit
that man
wow
I know the way you look at me
at you
look at yourself dude that man lets you
borrow him yup
to borrow his whole life
oh right
oh now you've done a kid
Henry
you should go
no I don't think so
David says Henry wrecked his painting he
hit him he gave him a little smack
upside the head
ugh
60s
get out of coming remember when he
burned a hole in the car seat I wailed
on him plenty right here in this room
the boy needs keeping in line
it's feeling bad for you
David wants to finish the painting
goddamn painting I know let's just
let him finish the painting
two more visits tops and then
I will come up with something you'll
come up dead
your things are set up in the barn
a please I'm taking Henry to the pool
even let him hit the kid it's crazy
60s man
the different time
find the sketch all this time he's
expected his privacy yeah
foreign
did she actually pose for that uh I
don't think so you know he knows a
figure from memory that's that's that's
an artist
oh boy
like one of your French girls
I got an alert
what's up
hahaha just a stupid like a fantasy
maybe I will bust your jaw you want to
bust your job I'm sorry it's not what
wow
you [__] creep my life it's pure
fantasy I got mixed up oh you got mixed
up it's just so beautiful oh my God
wrong choice of words yeah every step of
the way
I don't have anything you
got it all
and you don't even care I care plenty
your wife is a lonely woman now crossing
the line home yeah unappreciated
unsatisfied
untouched oh yeah I won't put you
through this God Walk you're crossing
the line you don't know what you've got
I know it damn well
interview
go back and be the most passionate
I'm gonna wreck that painting and we'll
know it's him
yep
or it's an act did you vote for him no I
did not pose for him show him your body
of course not did he touch you no did
you touch him oh
my God
he drew you're naked in his quarters up
there on board I don't know what he drew
he draws from memory that's what I was
worried about it
you knew I didn't want him here anymore
you never said I told you he hit our son
and you did not listen to me you didn't
listen
told him directly about this
inappropriate behavior he thinks that
you're lonely
all the time you're here I'm lonely oh
boy
they're having a real conversation you
brought me here put me in this house now
I just walk from room to room but you're
a shadow and I am here I am real so no
he didn't touch me but I wished he did I
oh
point of no return
for a moment it felt like my husband was
back and he
he and I wished he did too
by he he means you're yeah go to her
oh
you gotta start talking boy
I wanted to apologize
nothing happened with Lana
I know
she wasn't interested uh
uh well that's true that hurts buddy I'm
lonely you don't know what it's like I
just want to say goodbye
a con man
the worst kind
The Arrogant kind
she won't have you anywhere near her
it's mine
for all time
she is mine
he's just very disturbing
no he's gonna kill your ass you would
not see or speak to her ever again
oh
oh no he's gonna kill him
damn it
some kind of emergency all your
emergencies are fake
what is it
a small impact a few minutes ago cool
and tubing took ahead sleeping pretty
bad it's random out there God damn it
dude no visible signs of damage
David
he sure is cool in four
God damn it
David
you should have like a code word with
your wife yeah
safe word
huh
where the hell are you bathroom
where's my tag
my tag
put it back
he sabotage it what now nobody gets to
use
oh no Jesus Christ what did you do
oh
[Music]
no no no no
please let this be like you wanted him
to feel like you've just did painting
it's just alizarin Crimson everybody
don't worry I hope he's just trying to
make a point
enough
oh no he actually did it
oh
whoa
[Music]
oh and that same spinning hot head shot
too
the bookends tragedy bookends
yeah
you want him to experience it
[Applause]
what I can't just end like that
[Laughter]
truly alone
together
wow
I was messed up interesting
yes I was
[Music]
really well done because it kept going
the route
that you would expect it to go and then
right before it across that line there
we go
and then we're going a different way
yeah like every single time
it you know like right down to the whole
thing with the uh affair with not the
affair but kind of yeah uh with it with
the wife with the painting and yeah
getting all clothes you just never
you're like oh he's gonna hijack his
butt he does it's like I did not see
that coming where he would
murder them in the end yeah
I mean the guy's just so
try like just went too far he's he's
completely traumatized and also like as
detached as one could possibly become
yeah it was uh just said he's just
holding on to the fantasy as the one
thing giving him hope
yeah cracks truly truly a lesson in in
Hope sometimes being more cruel maybe
now you'll appreciate everything
wow that was amazing that was that was
so transportive what an experience that
was a movie yeah it really was this is a
couple is his length of a movie yeah
that's a real film right there
it has all like all the atmosphere and
all the yeah just breath of a film I
wish it had it didn't have the
open-ended foreign
like an open-ended ending I like when
things have an open-ended conclusion but
it doesn't I don't know I was like oh I
want to know that he killed him
he certainly should kill him he probably
should but it's like Josh hartnett's
become so dangerous he did that so fast
yeah yeah it's like he
he could only have been out there for I
mean it it must have been a minute but
it wasn't like an hour it doesn't seem
like it seems like it was like 15 or 20
minutes he was out there yeah if that
and yeah the acting was so amazing from
everyone here superb Aaron Paul playing
dual roles here really able to
distinguish it without her feeling he's
doing a Josh hartnet impression
Josh Hartnett going from that
All-American astronaut into
this Hollow Man Who Would seemed like
it'd seemed like he's weak when he's in
spike in space and it becomes like just
the monster by the end yeah
um yeah I love the aesthetic the
landscape I love how they chose to make
it
with the 60s at the time of masculinity
especially for men like this where
emotions were so much more detail like
where the ability to not really identify
how you're feeling can just consume you
and I love the
the the feigning of man who really is in
tune with his emotions with Josh
Hartnett
but he's really not obviously yeah you
know not for real yeah
oh wow that was that was wild that was
that was so wild it was so it was like
such a simple movie it was a simple it
was simple well because it's so so
complicated yeah it's it's so human and
I do appreciate like you said yeah that
they kind of let things just unfold in
what feels like a very gradual sort of
sensory sort of way and yeah it flirts
with all the things you're expecting and
it does a couple of them
and I don't know yeah there's such a
I don't know it felt like it had this
like nicely sort of
sophisticated tone because it's yeah
it's like it's not pulpy
but it does have just like this constant
sense of dread and ominousness and just
like something is wrong yeah and you're
just watching in like Advanced slow
motion this this horrible circumstance
get worse and yeah like I too I
appreciate the way they draw the
characters because your sympathies and
your
you know identifications drift and you
know you obviously meet them in a way
that demonstrates yeah Josh Hartnett is
you know certainly the more gregarious
social type and Aaron Paul is very
closed off uh and then I don't know yeah
it's like it didn't really ever feel
cliche like there's an easily cliche
version of this that they could have
gone down and you know it does a lot of
things that you would expect but just
not in the way or with the tone you
would it doesn't ever devolve into being
like a silly mellow drama like it does
feel like this harsh confusing situation
and when he's like breaking down uh the
David character he's like I have nothing
in this world any longer I'm basically
I'm alone up here with you you know on
this Mission we're just continuing to
drift out into Oblivion and like yeah
you you can fathom away in which this
almost could work
and it had especially given the time and
place that's in it like it just yeah
seems like a complete recipe for
disaster born of an attempted altruism
which is so tragic
and so horrible
that was gratifying yeah and I added
like again we've said it but like hats
off to the performances so much because
too like I it was nice surprise to see
Josh Hartnett back and see him you know
in a in a really you know juicy role
like this but also like Aaron Paul like
I I love Aaron Paul and for some reason
I always have like this same like
process when I see him in something new
I'm like oh yeah you know it's Aaron
Paul I'm gonna see kind of Aaron Pauling
it when I really jump into whatever the
thing is
you know it's easy to think of like
Aaron Paul and Jesse but like he's so
good at embodying
very different characters
and just in going through the spectrum
of emotion and what feels like such a
natural like when he's breaking down in
the woods it was like such a beautiful
unbroken take of that
and uh and yeah he always impresses me
and at the outset I'm always like I'm
gonna like him in it but you know I'm
gonna be aware of Tim and then you know
he'll slip into these roles in ways I I
don't expect and I think that's really
impressive and Kate Mara too I thought
she she did a really nice job kind of
being in this horribly unfortunate
position between the both of them
and yeah it's like you're in some ways
you're rooting for Cliff but Cliff is
also like not the best guy so like
you see how David is the better match in
a lot of ways and Cliff clearly does
care but yeah he just doesn't have touch
or access to his emotional Spectrum
enough at all to really kind of make
good on that and yeah it's like it's
just such a tragic story from every
possible angle and then finally at the
very end it gets you know super Twisted
again
and even that a whole bit with a Manson
the Manson gang at the top was gnarly
but uh yeah it's like it's it's funny
because it's such a again such a
naturalistic such a I know we name
checked uh Terence Malik it has that
sort of like tactile life thing about it
and yet it feels like very sci-fi
at the same time
even though the Sci-Fi the like the
physical sci-fi elements are like pretty
grounded
those are my favorite kind of Black
Mirror episodes when it's not really
about explaining a technological thing
that they're watching The Human
Experience and the association and how
it [__] with your mind based off of the
connection that you form with the
technology so even though this is not
necessary like it's a play on the on the
Avatar thing you know yeah uh which I
feel like one day they'll be able to
develop something like that which I feel
like would be really cool
um
but I I think having like the that as I
call family was very much like uh the
Manson family for sure like that's
exactly what they were going for there
and the Culkin prep that was it was you
know Severance is that the shortest time
it's not that Culkin I don't think it's
it's a difference yeah I think it's a
lot shorter yeah it's uh I don't know
that I yeah he's one of the coke yeah
yeah another Culkin with another very
culkiny name
well they're smart to really let that
feel insanely disturbing like the effect
of that uh just
you're you're left with the impact to
constantly have you
sympathize for Josh hartnett's character
so much to the point that even when he's
crossing the line
you're like you're across in the library
there's always this is how to do this
like but dude
I I understand why your your psyche has
led you down this path yeah yeah you
gotta reel it in but then when Aaron
Paul starts going off on him they were
like dude like yeah why you're so mad
you gotta get this guy you've got one
hour yeah a week yeah and you get to
spend all this time there yeah and he's
he's been through hell and back and you
have no idea what he's had to do and
he's just like this this love these kind
of men are constantly about having to
put on the display of composure at all
times
even when they're in their most frail
fragile States in their life they have
to just maintain some level of
everything's all right when it's not
um and like when he's going off at him
in the end you're like damn it we were
so close to just having some kind of
strange resolve but then you shattered
him there it's like you wanted to hurt
him yeah so bad when
you know it's like like no amount of
break they get allows them to have any
sort of refl like reflection or
understanding of what the other person
is like they you lose such sight of that
so if I loved how the human the
portrayals were of the of these men yeah
that their flaws get the best of them in
every way Aaron Paul specifically
like starting off as a person is like
very understanding and
because like yeah Josh Hartnett takes
advantage of him in every way because he
literally lends him his body to be able
to have an external thing he didn't have
to do and then he's going out there
saying like you're he's not man enough
for you and all that because
dealing with reality is too tough you
know this is a story of a man who does
who cannot successfully grieve
and when it was like that there's the
biggest fear moment to me was when Aaron
Paul like unloaded on him at the very
end yeah and it's like my wife says that
she makes her vomit the thought of you
um because too much yeah you're like God
I know what he did was like he crossed
the line but yeah one party is like
understanding it oh like across the line
put yourself in this case because they
do these nice nuanced touches with
getting you to understand the kind of
manner and Paul is with being closed off
and like also the whole thing about like
hitting the sun like you never see it
you never see him like actually hit the
key you never see this kid once get hit
but even when Josh Hartnett when
embodying Aaron Paul's body you know
hits the kid even Aaron Paul's like
understanding of that like you've got to
keep that kid in line you got to keep
that kid in line like you get the idea
of the mentality of this kind of who
this man is and you'd think that Aaron
Paul would be softer like we're going to
move to the countryside we're going to
isolate ourselves and he and he speaks
softly to his wife you know but you see
that there is this violent guy in him
okay this possessive guy and while Josh
Hartnett is like the bigger guy you know
like when Aaron Paul's like standing up
to him like that speaks to the prowess
of Aaron Paul's performance where when
he's getting in Josh harnett's face you
believe that Josh Arnett is like scared
yeah he's like intimidated by him
because he's in such a weak state that
you wouldn't actually expect him to
cross the line to such a violent path of
that Recreation and also punishment for
being hurt so bad that he really feels
like you know you're just not deserving
of this and and how painful it was what
kmar did but I love the way the way they
handled the kmar situation because
she easily could have been exactly the
affair woman you know like like I said
it just keeps going down like we both
said it just keeps going down the path
of
where you expect it to go and then the
second they start going to that line
they shift course you know the second
they start actually he starts getting
touchy feely with her
and like you know breathing on her neck
she's tempted by it and then she walks
away from the situation never gives into
the situation again and she stands up to
him and says like you manip you're being
manipulative you were trying to shower
me with gifts and trying to get into my
my mind and heart when you are just
taking advantage of a situation right
now like they made her someone very
mature in this versus what most things
would do which is exactly what I thought
they were gonna do yeah you know they
kept saying like this is where it's
going this is where it's going she's
going to sleep with this guy it's gonna
get sexual I'm gonna have an affair and
maybe Josh Arnett's gonna take over his
body yeah yeah I mean you know you think
it's going more that direction and the
way they have her hold her ground as a
strong woman like allowing her to have
her flaws and you know allowing her to
have her moments of weakness with
temptation but then giving her giving
giving you an understanding of where
she's coming from with that scene that
she has in Aaron Paul Barn where she is
lamenting all of her emotions
and he's actually finally listening to
her for the first time I thought was
such a nuanced scene because you know
they established so much that he's
willing to like
he's willing to hit someone you know and
like he's probably gonna hit her he's
probably gonna hit her right now yeah
and he doesn't instead he listens you
know so in some ways what Josh Harnett
did was the path to them healing the
relationship and then he just [__] it
up he went two weeks way too far yeah
it's like he illuminated all the things
that you're missing and yeah I love the
way he played that because it's almost
like yeah the kind of guy that Aaron
Paul that character is you kind of
believe like oh I guess you would just
be capable of missing what your wife is
clearly expressing through her demeanor
through this entire situation
and uh yeah I like to as much as you
know part of you wants the satisfaction
of like kill him man at the same time I
like the way they draw the scenario in
space because
it does seem like it's a two-man Mission
and if you know unless both of us are
going to perish we need the two of us up
here and now it's like there's nothing
else so it is kind of like a question
mark of just like the human survival
Instinct now and they are like bonded in
the worst way possible and that actually
kind of tickles my imagination a little
bit because I I
yeah
and part of me is like he could easily
kill him and he's got nothing else to
live for so they'll just both die but I
could also see how like in a Twisted way
maybe they just won't kill each other
and we'll just see this Mission out and
just be damaged and Beyond damaged
forever yeah and yeah just I don't know
the depth of depravity like yeah the the
true break within that David character
is something
fascinating because two it's like they
both get objectified in the in the
traditional way you think look sexual
but like the whole family is like this
object because Aaron Paul is yelling
like they're my like mine like the way
he yells at that one particular time
really feels like a yeah like you would
yell about a thing you own and by the
end you know the David character does
the same thing he he uses them as a
device to communicate his perspective
and it's just so sad and terrible
because yeah it's like they're also just
regular people you know being maimed by
a robot
thanks
yeah well and the other thing we haven't
talked about too is how the
one of the things about when you're in
space is
like one of the things they train like
with astronauts a lot and especially
these the crazy missions is it's mainly
a psychological game and
I love how even though they have the
accessibility to go back to Earth
if the Via these replicas
you still get that touch and Sensibility
of
the Mind drifting in the mind losing
itself insanity
you know yeah well and it almost begs
again it begs that question of Hope
because on the one hand you're like what
a beautiful advancement this would be
amazing you know if you could just plug
back into Earth and yeah like have a
direct link to your Humanity but then if
anything goes wrong that could be
absolutely catastrophic and cause even
greater psychological damage than if you
were just under the circumstance that
you're up here and you're isolated and
that's life for the foreseeable future
yeah it's like giving you the access
makes it worse when it goes away and
even worse when it goes away terribly
and so it is like a fascinating question
because I think anybody would be like
yeah if we had the capability to do that
absolutely but at the same time
I don't know like even though it is
maybe one of the more heightened parts
of the episode like yeah you'll have
people who are like this is an
Abomination and setting it in the 60s I
think makes that bit work it's like if
it had been modern day I don't think as
many people would be apt to like you
know Manson up and go kill the
Abomination robot you know automaton uh
but here you know in the time and place
it does seem to make you know it's it
rings truer of a Time less demystified
by crazy Tech and you have this one kind
of magic element which is the replica
and uh it's yeah that's the stuff to me
that gets kind of at the Twisted core of
you know what makes a Black Mirror
because you know this is clearly one of
the more like lyrical more Moody more
again Airy episodes I feel like they've
done a couple like even though it's not
like tonally similar it kind of reminded
me of uh
I feel like San ju pero kind of has a
similar quality even that one even
though that one's more like
uh less sad but yeah like this this core
twistedness that just feels so Bleak and
and sad but also like human
human despite how you know technological
it is I guess
dark depths of the human core yeah
quite an ethereal experience ladies and
gentlemen that was fun yeah it's fun and
all the most messed up it messed me up
I'm very much uh
I think it's gonna be the last one we
shoot today on my brains my brain's not
just wife from this I had we shot the
first one and then I had to like edit
and do the thumb and upload I was like I
kind of took the window now and now we
should watch this I was like wow my
mind's just messed up well yeah it's one
of those episodes that ends in your life
yeah I just kind of want to sit in
silence and contemplate I'm like how
terrible my soul feels right now the
whole time I was like how do I feel
right now because I I don't know how I
film on this weird Vortex of a situation
because because there's so many it's
sewn layered in nuanced with so many
vast emotions it's such a wide array at
unlike on every frame of this episode
that like oh man my my I I am watching
this way at the wrong hour after after a
very long day yeah
go hop in the Pod and take it out I
gotta talk about this this is really
hard yeah yeah the hardest time talking
about is
[Music]
um but that was that was beautiful yeah
that was great that was that was amazing
beautiful it was truly amazing that's
what's one for the books Unforgettable
um all right guys well thanks for being
here and we will
um
soon
[Music]